حقيقه هذا الامر اللي هو السجال الطائفي
والعقائدي يظهر باوضح صوره حينما نتحدث عن
شخصيات معاويه بن ابي سفيان وعن الدوله
الامويه ايضا يعني اعطيك مثال يكفيك الان
ان تقول اسم معاويه فقط دون ان تتكلم شيء
انت لم تقل اي شيء قلت بس فقط اسم معاويه
فجاه يشتعل السجال والجدال والاخذ والرد
وبين محب وكاره وفي كل مكان
حتى تيك توك يعني يا جماعه انا لسه ما قلت
شيء ما تحدثت عن معاويه يعني لسه المسلسل
ما عرض لم يعرض مسلسل
اشتعل الجدل والسجاد هذا هو صوره من صور
المواقف المسبقه والمغلقه تجاه احداث
التاريخ او حتى احداث الحياتيه اليوميه
هذا هذا السجال الطائفي تسبب في يعني يعني
ظلم معرفي وحجب عنا الاطلاع الثقافي
والثراء المعرفي الواسع الذي ممكن ان
نستلهمه من دراسه ومعرفه شخصيه معاويه بن
ابي سفيان انا من رايي واق ولها انه شخصيه
معاويه بن ابي سفيان حقيقه هو واحد من
اعظم عباقره السياسه في تاريخ العالم وليس
في التاريخ الاسلامي فحسب واحد من اعظم
عباقره وصناع السياسات في العالم قد تقول
ان هذا الكلام مبالغه قلت كيف هذا الكلام
انا اقول لك هذا الكلام ليس مبالغ كيف
نعرف اثر الشخص السياسي واثره العظيم
ونجعله
من الشواهد